big congratulations to you oh my god
thank you so much how's the feeling
having this moon person for best new
artist in your hand
i mean i'm like i'm walking through this
like these back hallways i'm fully
sobbing i'm like i have to call my best
friend i have to call my mom i'm really
moved i'm really shocked you've had a
big big year i know
i am i'm really shocked she's dessert
i'm just like over here twirling her
brain
oh my gosh honey it's okay and you
should be crying because this is these
are celebratory tears yeah you've had a
big year and i love the fact that you
dedicated this award this category your
win to the queer community why did you
want to do that i mean i think i just
owe them so much like i my community is
everything to me and um
the way that you know the lgbtq
community has embraced me so
wholeheartedly
throughout this year i feel like i've
really found myself as a human being um
and i feel like it's definitely
translated into my music and and the
love and the support that i've received
i really feel is down to
you know the human connection of that i
think that anybody who resonates with my
music is really resonating with what
they find
in themselves in the music and so any
sort of success i have i i owe to those
people and so much of that is is the
queer community and you've also found so
much self-discovery within yourself in
the process of being a musician haven't
you yeah definitely i mean i think that
the fact that my my first
you know kind of big wave in music was
an overly queer song
um
just made it all the more
magical to me you know it's it wasn't
i felt like it wasn't something that was
just
mine it feels like it's something that's
so much
bigger than that because of the fact
that it's a queer song on
mainstream radio which just i grew up
not that was never even like an inkling
i didn't this is like i fell into some
weird time hole um
so it's really amazing to me that people
have been so supportive and that this is
a fan vote it's so moving oh this isn't
just yours it's for so many out there
tonight and you definitely are aware of
that but have so much fun thank you i
know i still look like a million bucks
after such a long show such a long car
down to my glam theme i mean in this
t-90 little waist it was just like a
full display
congratulations deb thank you amazing
[Music]